à 6h26 et gérard leclerc qui rentre de
son café tranquillement mais c'est le
matin c'est la dengue gérard est pas
complètement rayé qui l'a pas vu qu'on
était à l'antenne
voilà je vais les chercher le café mais
voilà alors ce masque anti corona qu'on
va vous présenter il est composé à main
d'or et de diamant à votre avis combien
coûte-t-il il est considéré comme le
masque le plus cher au monde et est ce
qu on est à quatre cent cinquante mille
neuf cent quatre-vingt mille carrément
un million trois noms pour ce masque
anti cauris j'espère qu'à ce prix là on
a le trac pas le corps et les russes
beaucoup de messages très trash des
internautes qui se sont réjouis
d'apprendre que donald trump a été
positif
oco vide l'image la plus partagée
d'ailleurs ce week-end sur twitter est
celle d'un montage du personnage de
donald trump dans les simpson dans un
cercueil il s'agit de ce qu'on appelle
un fait qu'un des simpson n'ont jamais
mis en scène la mort du président
américain mais on a constaté un pic de
recherche sur google autour de cette
photo souvent accompagnées de messages
souhaitant clairement le décès de donald
trump
contrairement à tout achat kg ont montré
la chambre président américanisé une
chambre une cuisine un salon orné d'un
chandelier et un bureau afin de
continuer à travailler pendant son
hospitalisation voilà senna champ voilà
c'est la nicotine accord
c'est la réponse est à bravo
effectivement il ya de 3600 diamant 250
grammes d'or est effectivement thomas
pour répondre à ton interrogations il
marche il ya quand même un film énorme
supérieure la n 80 m c'est la plus haute
non c'est un millionnaire heures la n 99
et ça tombe de ma chaise je veux
m'excuser je tourne de mâcher davantage
autonomes à tous ces responsables de
dire des choses comme ça dans son petit
fils instances sanitaires jeudi 6 h
demain dit dulko stress visibilité à la
silhouette plus gagné à les éplucher
allez monsieur toussaint dont qui a
plein d'idées sur chez vous et qui va ça
va dans tous les sens dit il faut
laisser filer le virus on laisse non
j'ai parlé à l'essaimage de l'ariège
laissez moi vous allez réussir à
comprendre ce que je veux dire ma prix
favorite c'est la strangulation et le
compresseur en fait une compression des
fesses pour tout en l'air et je saute
dessus avec mes fesses
ça peut être très dangereux non je veux
surtout quand gerry gaz s'ils ne vous
étonnez pas du tout l'été que c'était
terminé il a dit tout l'été que c'était
un ami n'est que la seconde vague
c'était de la pure fiction je les samoa
et majorettes il va y avoir un plateau
alors que c'est ce que je dis depuis un
mois de jeu renard en un tournoi je vous
ai dire donc je rasais du vent plus
insupportable je vous ai dit depuis le
début si vous ne supportez plus alors à
ce moment là vous n'avez peut-être plus
besoin d'être en société mais si nous
sommes encore en capacité de nous
écouter je vais vous donner le point
leroy décoche se fait mettre au tapis
vert les gosses dont ça me fait penser à
l'amérique puisque c'est les îles en
centrale je vais annoncer face à ce
monsieur qui disait que c'était de la
folie qui avait rien que c'était une
invention carré pas de reprise
puisqu'elle y est vous avez déjà
maintenant parce qu'une vague c'est
quand ça monte aussi oh bah oui ça
s'appelle ah bah bravo ça c'est de
l'argumentaire franc mais sa volée un
peu trop bas pour moi au niveau je
respecte je vous le dis ça suffit
maintenant je nettoie les oreilles
depuis 12 ans on est nettoyeur
d'oreilles de père en fils dans ma
famille tout le monde nettoie les
oreilles très sale
c'est absolument immonde
je me lave pourtant dit y est non pas
des fois il ya des bonnes siestes avec
les femmes
mais oui ça fait partie de la vie c'est
joli et très joli j'ai très bien joué
mais il va arriver pour la soirée sur
son 41,7 festival de cannes la folie je
suis pas du tout fan ses jeux sur l'ale
casse pas trois pattes à oensingen
mauvaise c'est très très bon ça l'est un
mari qui prennent il est trop chou et
m'aide à monter sur le devant du bateau
il tient il fait attention que je tombe
pas là ont raison de se retrouver un peu
dans titanic
[Musique]
une manière de participer à l'opération
octobre rose le mois de sensibilisation
au cancer du sein
la mairie de saint pierre de
varengeville installé en bord de route à
l'entrée de la ville un lave-linge repas
en rose avec des fleurs qu'ils sentent
du tambour une idée un peu décalé
reconnaît la mairie mais évidemment les
photos publiées sur les raisons pour
évoquer un tollé bon pour connaître
évidemment associés les femmes un
lave-linge n'est pas l'idée du siècle
bon allez claude et les deux pieds dans
le même sabot sais pas si tu mets ta
gueule des granges
[Musique]
avant oui c'est mieux c'est mieux je
l'exprimerai au dessus des peurs pas
coincé du tout
il ya déjà des échanges tous les jours
pour savoir ce qu'on a mangé ce qu'on
achète aux courses mais le sexe c'est
les changes victimes coincées en gros
s'il n'y a pas des changes pour savoir
ce qu'on bouffe à midi il ya un monde
qui change tout ça comme on laisse le
soin à bree gabrielle habitées
les conneries d'affilée par a dévoilé
les cabines téléphoniques vote urinoirs